thank you for joining us i'm john
langler he was killed on a hectic night
here in las vegas
25 year old jorge gomez shot to death by
metro police at the federal courthouse
during a black lives matter protest
today prosecutors decided the officers
involved will
not face charges hector mejia live in
our newsroom with the latest on the case
hector
good afternoon in a 79 page report the
da's office says the actions of the four
officers who fired the deadly gunshots
were not criminal in nature the report
starts with pictures of an earlier
encounter between
jorge gomez and other officers the night
of the black lives matter protest
back on june 1st of last year gomez seen
wearing a
tactical vest and openly carrying two
guns including
an illegal short barreled rifle
according to that report
it also revealed gomez hid behind a
power box at las vegas boulevard and
fremont street when the crowd
was ordered to disperse four officers in
that incident
felt threatened and drew their guns but
did not fire
later that night within one minute after
metro police officer shea mccollonas
was shot in the head in a separate
incident near circus circus
gomez reportedly appeared again in
downtown
this time he approached officers
guarding the federal courthouse
gomez ignored commands one officer fired
low
lethal rounds and gomez then ran
northbound on las vegas boulevard
fell and picked up a gun he dropped
officers responding to the call
at circus circus came across this
disturbance
four of them fired the deadly rounds at
gomez that reported he raised or
pointed his firearm at them and none of
the officers
wore a body camera meanwhile gomez's
family has a lawsuit against the
officers saying
surveillance video shows he did nothing
wrong
all you got is the officer saying that
he raised the weapon
but the video clearly shows that he did
not
so you want us to believe the liars that
are las vegas metropolitan police
department
today we also learned gomez suffered
eight gunshot wounds the report also
says
gomez's father told an investigator that
the black lives matter movement
recruited gomez in oregon
and that they were paying him to protest
today's report is in addition to a
public
fact-finding review which we told you
about back in april
there's a lot of detail in the 79 page
report we uploaded all of those pages on
our website
eight news now dot com reporting from
our newsroom hector mejia
8 news now hector thank you very much